you know how we can find out more about
me oh wait no that's ping no no no then
that's not going to work
no because the Bing will actually just
give you some basic information but
there's a surprise if we look me up on
Google you ready to be surprised
I am not ah there we go
anyone see the surprise this is the this
is the smartest search engine in the
world do you see any problem there
anything a little off oh I always gets
up ring my name but that's not the
problem you don't see no one sees a
little like some little problem there
maybe okay
they sure it's not you That's not me who
do you agree truly or instantiate no no
this guy isn't I figured out who he was
he's a contractor in New York
okay he kills buildings and that's what
he does That's not me
this is the smartest search and engine
in the world okay they've been running
people who are not me on my bio for as
long as I can remember I pissed them off
or something did I did I irritate
someone there you think could be yeah
I'm sure it's innocent right everything
they do is innocent right it's it's all
the out it's always the algorithm right
it's never the people there are no
mischievous programmers right just
because I've been a programmer since I
was 13 and I've been mischievous my
whole life dude playing pranks like that
my whole that doesn't mean any of those
people work for Google it's impossible
maintains the Google blacklist well I
have an article coming out in that so
yeah I know I know more about their
blacklist than they do at this point you
know I have here's my thing right here
see there are my slides it's 54 slides
ok no slides nothing up my sleeve I'm
just going to talk to you as people it's
a small group maybe a few of you I've
already chatted with a few names I even
remember this is Eugene because this is
Kate let's see one of you guys well
that's Dennis obviously that's one of
you guys is Mike there Mike and who's
the one who heard the lecture last night
from Nate personally like and Oh others
too didn't they mention me by any chance
he did oh nice yeah we spoke together
last week at the National Academy
expressing some concerns I guess you
could say all right let me tell you why
I'm just going to talk to you as people
as human beings and tell you kind of a
little journey of research I've been on
ok let me start out by saying that I'm
the most skeptical person I know and it
seems to me all scientists are skeptical
people they're supposed to be that's the
idea and what I'm saying is on a scale
of 1 to 10 I'm a 10 ok you never want to
have a journal send a paper to me for
review never I'm one of those people a
professor of mine very famous historian
of science at Harvard many years ago I
Bernard Cohen and if you know of Cohen
he founded the history of science
department they're extraordinary man
what a character I mean even he used to
complain about how persnickety I was ok
I'm very skeptical so that's one thing
you need to know
second thing is and this you probably
already know is that researchers tend to
exaggerate the importance of their
research anyone know anyone like that
anyone ever maybe done that and is
willing to admit it I have especially
when I was working with pigeons okay I
definitely look back on that and I think
what the hell did I say because but you
know we do that when people who are
researchers I've been a researcher for
almost 40 years sometimes we do it just
because we're enthusiastic about our
work and that's I think fine sometimes
we do it because we're trying to impress
somebody a journalist Dean who else you
need to impress uh well a granting
agency a funding agency right with me
sometimes it was a girlfriend
hey you got to see the research I'm
doing I want to see my etchings my
research asset edgings I mean the
reasons why people exaggerate and I have
I've exaggerated the importance of my
work what I'm about to tell you about
the search engine manipulation effect
okay I find myself in the opposite
position I started exploring this a few
years ago I thought I would find
something and it would be very really
really small but I thought that would be
worth something I thought that would
still be important to find this really
small thing and I'll give you details
shortly that's what I thought I'd find
that's not what I found in fact I didn't
believe what I found and now I find
myself you know a few years later in
this very awkward situation because the
more I have learned about this the more
concerned I've become and I don't even
have a way to communicate this to people
generally speaking I don't even have a
way to communicate it because I don't
even want to believe it
so it's odd I've never been in this
position before in my life and that's
why I'm just talking to you as a person
as a as a fellow human being if you're
if you're a parent I've talked to you as
a fellow parent I have four kids of my
own and two stepchildren and I you know
when you're a parent especially you're
you automatically start to think about
you know twenty years from that 150
years from now and so on right and I
swear I don't I don't have a way of
explaining how odd and I think important
you know this work is and it's in and I
think it's bigger than I even think it
is if you see what I mean no let me
explain
okay I I still am directing about a
dozen research project so this is a very
small takes up very little of my time
okay take my time divided by 12 it
doesn't take up that much of my time
next year I'll have coming out of the
biggest sexual orientation study ever
conducted where the 300,000 people in
more than 90 countries and in and it's a
good study man it's it's you know
there's actually some some discoveries
in the study and I do research on stress
management and creativity parenting love
whatever and Google to me was just a
cool toy it's like the coolest toy ever
that's all it was to me nothing else at
the beginning of 2012 gee what day was
it
Oh could it have been is January 1st New
Year's Day how could I forget
I got about six or seven emails all to
me all from Google saying that my
website was being blocked okay okay so
hello okay I've been hacked everyone's
hacked right
uh but when I but then I started there
were so there were technical aspects of
this which as a programmer I I got very
curious about so first of all the fact
that Google even has a blacklist was
news to me and then as I looked into it
more and found out that they are
actually having any given day millions
of websites on their blacklist that was
news to me who just said yep and who are
you I don't know maybe that's the real
guy maybe he maybe we need the
contractor here
so I didn't know that and I started
looking into it and then but then again
I got kind of curious because I realize
ok
they got crawlers bah-bah-bah they can
find now where now and they're gonna
make mistakes whatever and and of course
when they find malware it makes sense
that they're on their search engine
they're gonna put a warning so I was ok
with all that I think made sense to me I
just had to find the malware get rid of
it bla bla bla some aspects didn't make
sense the fact that you know it takes a
split second to get on the black list
and it can take you weeks to get off the
black list doesn't still doesn't make
sense to me you know exactly they have
no customer service department who can
help you you know there's some aspects
of it that we're like I thought were a
little odd but what I thought was really
odd because I'm a programmer was that
when I tried to access my main website
or the kind of the you know the
ancillary websites that have a
psychological test using Firefox or
Safari I found I couldn't get to them
and I thought what that doesn't make
sense
Firefox is not Google it's not Chrome I
don't get it
Safari is certainly not it's come to
that's a competing company and Firefox
is a non-profit and I said I and I said
wait a minute how could Firefox what's
the mechanism what is the mechanism by
which this is occurring so I have an
article coming out that's all about
Google's black list it's a long long
piece it's got all kinds of things
there and even even their financial
motive for using the blacklist is in
there which no one's ever revealed
before so but I'm not gonna tell you
about that I'm just going to tell you
that because this happened which was a
very minor incident I started looking at
Google a little differently with a
little bit more critical eye like I look
at everything in life I started looking
at Google that way and you know I found
things that were genuinely disturbing of
course I I quickly got up to speed on
their business model which still to this
day I astounds me that how few people
know this I'm sure everyone in this room
knows that Google is actually an
advertising agency that's that's that's
all they are they're an advertising
agency with a brilliant method of data
collection that's all
the method of data collection of course
is you give people lots of free stuff
like a really cool search engine and
then you take the information and you've
basically leverage that with companies
who are trying to want to sell products
and services it's brilliant it's a
brilliant model and people don't see
what's going on you know so I wrote a
piece for Time magazine about that which
is called a googles dance about this
kind of odd so I just kept kind of
looking at different aspects of the
company and I thought wow this is one
after another I was saying things which
I thought were just true genius and as I
understand it the guys who created this
did so not too far from here yeah so you
know so this should be especially
meaningful to you because I want to make
it clear that I think that when these
these two guys came up with the search
engine that certainly wasn't the first
one it was probably the 21st roughly
Eugene yeah so I don't think they set
out to create a monster and I don't
think they even set out to create an
advertising agency I think that came
later because there's a there's a guy
who actually left their name Witek
I think his name is who actually who was
a pretty high-ranking guy who was there
at the beginning who then actually left
the company and published a piece on
Lange saying wile if Google and he
basically said in the beginning it was
just this cool corporate anomaly and
then it became this advertising agency
he said and so he left no of course most
people don't leave Google it's very you
know people don't leave field because
there's a lot of money at stake but okay
toward the end of 2012 you know thinking
about various issues related to Google
which again I think again Larry and
Sergey never intended I don't think they
intended the ad thing initially and I
don't think they intended these other
things that have been creeping up on me
and that I'm learning more about and
going I don't think they intended any of
this stuff but anyway toward the end of
2012 I was looking at the literature
it's it's a literature of studying
consumer behavior and it's it's pretty
extensive and is looking at that
literature on how search rankings affect
consumer choices and it's fascinating
and I found it to be fascinating I mean
for one thing you know people pay a lot
of attention to what's at the top of the
list on the first page and much less
attention to what's below and their eye
tracking studies showing for example
that you know they're gonna look at
what's at the top of the list even if
very obviously there's something much
better that's found in position 7 or 8
the I might glance down when it comes
right back up to the top and ultimately
50% of all clicks go to the top two
slots 95% of all clicks go to the first
page okay this is this has been shown
repeatedly so higher is better right and
that's why a lot of companies spend a
lot of money on SEO search engine
optimization because they're trying to
go up another notch because you can
literally calculate for any given
industry how much money that's worth to
you if you can just jump up one notch
huh do you know how much Justin
now you should know that justin is one
of my sons and he works in internet
marketing in the Bay Area and there is
yes ma'am what is your name you realize
there's so few people here I can
actually get to know all your names and
run a big website
for 17 years I used to be one of Google
Adsense is top 500 publishers and I was
making around $200,000 a year on this
website and then dandy and you were the
first page that's on the first page of
course you were I've got something
around his first week and the
interesting thing was when panda hit
Adsense did not know it was coming
those guys were all being paid on
commissions by how well they helped
their publishers now other publishers
did and they were furious they were
totally caught the guy they could not
talk to the search people they had the
whole department wrote a white paper to
complain about what the search people
had searched and ruin their income
that's training basically so I found
that interesting they don't talk to each
other well there's a wonderful piece
which I recommend to all of you if
you're not familiar with it written by
the head of Springer in in Germany which
those are the largest publishing
conglomerate in Europe called fear of
Google and it's all about what's
happened to search rankings of various
subsidiaries of his company and how a
lot of CEOs just live in absolute fear
moment-to-moment terror of what Google
might do to their search rankings
because if you if you suddenly overnight
so just just a clarification and it was
a revision of the search algorithm it
was a major I'm February 28 it was
overnight
know what the hell I drop I have been on
450,000 Google pages me and my research
and I dropped to 60,000 but with me they
didn't stop so now I'm down to you have
to look it up yourself September and
then it falls off now it is this sort of
where that slowly prejudged my
usefulness of my site even though it's
useful all year round well keep this in
mind what Anne is saying is very
important because what she's saying is
you know that there are decisions that
are made right well actually not that
far from here which direction is it I
don't know I'm disoriented but there are
decisions that that that impact our
lives and we have no idea how these
decisions are made into there's no
transparency we have no control over
what's happening but they affect our
lives I am going to tell you about
something that is impacting most of the
world right now and in ways that go far
beyond elections that's what I've been
realizing so we saw the power of these
search rankings on consumer behavior and
we thought about it and we said yeah I
wonder if if people really believe that
what's higher is better and maybe they
also believe that what's higher is truer
and maybe that could impact you know
their opinions on something that they're
uncertain about so we ran an experiment
and this is about January 2013 and we
created our own version of Google which
is called could doodle but it works
exactly like Google does but it but it
isolates people from the full ant
Internet okay so they're trapped in our
world our search engine world and we
thought let's see if we could use a
search engine to influence voter
preferences that was the idea we used as
our election a real election the 2010
election for Prime Minister of Australia
Julia Gillard versus the same he's the
current Prime Minister Abbott yeah and
so we use that election why because
we're going to use our subjects we're
all going to be American
who probably would know very little
about these people and that's good
because that makes them by definition
undecided and that's what we wanted to
start with people who are undecided and
we set up but I'm what's I'm very proud
of we set up an extremely well designed
experiment so well designed that
experiments with this design eventually
made it into PNAS just just in August
because they're randomized they're
controlled they're counterbalanced
they're double-blind I mean absolutely a
gold standard or research so that we you
know are results would be unambiguous
and the basic design is very simple
people who are randomly assigned to
group a when they're doing research on
the candidates for this election they
end up seeing search results which are
biased in favor of candidate a by my in
favor I mean that if a search result is
higher it's going to have more praise
for that candidate and possibly more
criticism of the other so and people in
Group B they're going to have the same
thing but for supporting the other
candidate candidate B and people in
Group C they're getting an alter
alternated search search results so in
other words they're getting search
rankings that don't favor either
candidate very simple very clean design
and I thought that if we you know we
first asked people some general
questions about you know who would who
you know here here's a brief description
of the candidates you know who would you
vote for who do you think of questions
like that and and sure enough we get in
the in the very right at the outset
before they do a search we get numbers
like right smack in the middle we get 50
50 pretty much you know for all
statistical purposes that's what we get
no preference which is what we want
right we thought okay we haven't do a
search maybe again the people in these
bias groups they're gonna shift a little
bit at least the other answers to these
some of these questions we thought
they'd shift and I thought frankly that
we could boost the proportion of people
favoring either
candidate I predicted we could boost
that proportion by two to three percent
two to three percent and of course you
never know what you're going to get
right but that was my I always make
predictions sometimes to actually work
in that first experiment we boosted the
proportion of people favoring either
candidate by 48 percent in a search
lasting only 10 to 15 minutes 48 percent
yes if you want to think of it as a
hundred people and I've got 50 for each
and I'm boosting it by 50 percent that
means 25 or 20 to be precise 24 more
people so now basically I've got 3/4 of
my population after one search and it
wasn't just the proportion of people
saying they would vote liking went up
Trust went up overall impression every
single measure we have at five different
measures all moved dramatically
dramatically in the predicted direction
now there was something else that was
disturbing because I can tell you these
were blatantly biased search results
blatantly okay I think there's no
possible doubt and we asked people
whether they were aware basically that
there was you know something odd about
the search rankings we couldn't use the
word biased obviously because as a
leading question the point is it
appeared that 75 percent of our
participants in that first question
seemed completely oblivious to the fact
that they were seeing by a search
rankings that they were being
manipulated
so naturally the next thing to do with
another group was you know we thought
about it we said well maybe we can mask
the effect so instead of having you know
you know Guillard Gilad Gilad Gilad
Gilad you know all the way down the
first page what is in the fourth
position we just put in one search
result that favors the other candidate
by the way these are all real search
results to connecting to real webpages
and they can roam around as they please
just as they would in any search engine
so they can read whatever they want and
spend as much time as they want in any
you know what maximum 15 minutes so now
we've switched the fourth position the
percentage we still got a dramatic shift
in fact a shift in this case which we
call the BMP for vote manipulation power
pleasant 48% it was 63% these are big
numbers but now 85% of the participants
seem to be oblivious to the manipulation
unaware so we said what if we just move
that in the next experiment to the third
position because right higher you are
the more power you have over people just
move it to the third pisser's and all we
get again a huge shift and 100% of our
participants were now oblivious to the
manipulation that's all we did is switch
the third position okay so this was this
was not what I was expecting and I was
concerned we had gone to great lengths
in picking subjects we did not use
College sophomores okay we spent money
we did you know advertisements in the
community we went to nursing homes I
mean we did whatever it took
we wanted to have a you know groups that
were representative and as many
demographic categories as possible of
the general voting population so very
very diverse groups in these experiments
but they were small and everyone we had
even at least were very diverse groups
was basically living in the San Diego
area fourth experiment we go nationwide
online more than 2000 subjects from all
50 states again very diverse group we
get a shift of 39 percent and again very
few people aware that they're being
manipulated there's something wrong with
the rankings now in this case we've got
a net nationwide study we've got a lot
more subject so now we can start to look
at demographics we can look at subgroups
right so obviously what's one subgroup
you want to look at
you want to look at the people who were
aware that they were being manipulated
because presumably those people don't
shift right so this is now big enough so
we could look at those people and we
found that they were very much aware
because we left them not only you know
check a box but they could type up a
paragraph and just you know complaining
about what was wrong with the search
rankings these people were very much
aware that these were highly biased
search rankings but they didn't shift by
39% they shifted I believe by 47
something like that percent they shifted
even more than people who were not aware
of the manipulation by me if I were
aware that 90% of the articles I found
said Bob Dylan is great singer I might
just because 90% said he was a big good
singer
be more convinced that if I Sol
alternate he's a good singer he's a bad
singer so if I look at that as truth
behind the differences I would be more
convinced the truth was the number of
articles we on that song but remember
they have access to all the pages well I
look at the page and I see 90% saying
Bob Dylan it's great singer thank you
could be and you're lazy like everyone
else that so you don't go beyond the
first page is what you're saying
yeah no I'll buy that I'll buy that
right maximum and how many pages were
they like how many 30 pages that I would
urge you all if you want to see that the
details please click on that you know
the website for this series of talks and
they just click and you'll actually have
the PNAS article and all the supplements
yes so they have up to 15 minutes and
there they have 30 pages which are
spread out over real I know in real life
searches are on average or very very
short and in real life there are a lot
more pages available right there are
billions but in real life in fact 95% of
everybody never leaves the first page
and again 50% of all clicks go to the
top two items so you know in fact are
the if you look at the time
distributions and the click
distributions there is all in that
article you'll find that we are just
dead on consistent with what's been
found in consumer research just dead on
are our subjects behaved in these are
experiments exactly like everyone
behaves until relatively recently at her
number searches were single word
searches and same thing happen in
libraries as well to when computer
systems entered libraries yeah yeah good
point
okay so I'll by what Mike said you know
I I think I think you could say that if
you're if you're aware of again that
that not just this search result and the
corresponding webpage favors a candidate
but all of these search results seem to
favor the candidate that's kind of
social proof you could call it maybe
you're even thinking ah the search
engine itself the algorithm obviously
prefers Donald Trump so that that's and
you know and I trust the search engine
who knows but the point is being aware
of the bias does not protect people from
it not at all
it makes them flip even more so now we
had four experiments and we've learned a
lot
the fourth experiment was also large
enough so we could look at other
demographic groups because and again
what did I predict I predicted there
would be some damn differences among
demographic groups but they would be
small I was wrong again okay some
demographic groups were highly
vulnerable to this effect which we
eventually called the search engine
manipulation effect or seam SEM II some
demographic groups were highly
vulnerable others far less vulnerable
the most vulnerable demographic group
that we found was moderate Republicans
what percentage of those people did we
shift anyone wanna guess eighty percent
eighty percent toward any either
candidate eighty percent the next one
after that was moderate libertarians
that's consistent that's consistent I
mean I think they shifted by over
seventy percent so you know we have the
ability now to look at them aggressive
the specific numbers for these
demographic roofs don't matter all that
matters is the finding that there are
dramatic differences among demographic
groups in terms of their vulnerability
to seem that's very important from a
practical perspective because if you
know that and you know and you have
massive profiles on people you not only
know you know everything about their
demographic characteristics it puts you
in a much much better position to change
people's opinions yes what is your name
crystal
planet okay I show some moderate
Republicans stories on Fox News if I if
the same sort of thing happens reading
newspapers or looking at TV news as
happens with a search engine I would
expect a shift even though people know
that Fox News is biased I would expect
the shift to occur
among the people who listen to boxes
even if they come to me I know that this
is advice yes it's called the Fox News
effect that's been studied a terribly
it's been quantified it's been studied
in the context of markets in which Fox
News is just entering that's how it was
studied and so you you watch and see
what happens whether you can shift votes
to the right and in fact they shift
predictably to the right it's very small
shift so these shifts are about 1% or a
little under 1% they're not big shifts
but they're enough to flip closed
elections the same research also shows
that in those markets when another
competing you know media source comes in
that's not consistent with Fox's
politics then the effect starts to get
smaller so yes now you're talking about
a world by the way which is the normal
political world in which there's
competition among different you know
viewpoints I'm talking about something
completely different
I'm talking about a media media a medium
in which there is virtually no
competition you see so here you are
you're undecided and now you go to this
particular medium which you have a high
degree of trust for and there is no
competition and don't tell me that being
is competition because it's not and
Yahoo just signed a deal with Google so
that Google Google search results are
now going to be incorporated into Yahoo
believe it or not they've just given up
and not only that most countries in the
world certainly all through Europe
ninety percent of all search is done on
Google my wife and I just lived in the
Fiji Islands for a while I was appointed
a professor at the University of the
South Pacific and Fiji okay crazy thing
to do even if somebody has to do it yeah
but even Fiji even in Fiji ninety
percent of all search is done on Google
so yeah
you provided a ranking and ran
experiments against that ranking but the
ranking was really pretty much the same
for every for every participant in the
study in the real world now Google and
others have a an understanding of the
individual that I can choose a ranking
which would move them in some specific
direction based on their particular
committees friend that would seem to me
to be a very interesting experiment this
is essentially the AdWords model yes
well we've been doing that I you know we
looked at that issue the the
personalization issue and yes if you
personalize then guess what you can have
a bigger impact so what we call the VMP
that's shift that percent shift gets
larger and there's another advantage to
personalizing by the way because if you
personalize then no regulator can ever
see you doing anything because the
regulators they never see those personal
history things that are going on to
people they never see them fifth
experiment so at this point you know
everything we've done is disturbing or
getting big numbers but you know these
are all eligible voters it's true but
you know it's still you know we're using
the Australian election with Americans
so we went to India early 2014 we
basically set up our our mock search
engine and recruited more than 2,000
2,100 people to be precise all
throughout India almost every Indian
state the only requirements they had to
be eligible voters they must not have
voted yet because the vote in India is
actually spread out over a few weeks and
they see eligible voters must not have
voted yet oh and they had to be fluent
in English high level of English fluency
which is and English is actually the one
of the two official languages in India
so it's easy to find people who speak
English quite well
and we set it up so now people are
randomly assigned to one of three groups
since there were three major candidates
Modi who ultimately won Kedra wall and
Gandhi and I predicted you're probably
figuring out now that my predictions
suck okay I predicted that we would get
a shifts
I thought of between two and three
percent or nothing because these are
real people in the middle of a real
election where they're being bombarded
especially India the campaign is much
more intense than it is in the u.s.
they're just bombarded oh and they had
to be undecided they had to be undecided
haven't voted yet they're undecided and
so on and we compensated people by
making a donation to a big children's
charity in India some people were paid
but most people actually we they did it
in order to activate the the donation I
was wrong again
okay what we found and again you want to
look at the PNAS paper for the details
but the bottom line is you can very
easily shift people even in India even
in the middle of a big election by at
least 20% 22% you'll see that figure in
there there are other figures too
because this is a more complicated
situation than the ones running in the
US but I stand by that you can easily
shift people by at least 20% in the
middle of a real election and notice
we're doing this with one hit one
experience what would happen if people
were just kind of doing their everyday
searches not just on candidates but on
issues that are election related and
they're doing searches on immigration an
abortion whatever it may be but you know
they end up with search results that are
a favor one candidate what happens if
they do that day after day for weeks or
months so again I think all of our
numbers are either they're low yeah yes
sir your name well what's your name
anyway see David hello that's my middle
name
and he did Wester hand up over here was
I
okay just wasn't davidson he's holding
his head up okay so also 99.5% of the
people in the study showed no awareness
of the manipulation and again huge
variations among demographic groups and
some shifts as over that were over 60%
if that one shift in one group was over
70% so those five studies are in PNAS
those are experiment stations Aaron
Kenny is now proceedings the National
Academy of Sciences they came out in
August yeah if you use that no no no we
paid the additional whatever it was I
think was five thousand dollars so
everyone has free access that's how much
they charge you so no everyone is free
access so that's that but we've gone
beyond that and this is where honestly I
think this becomes for me disturbing
because what I realized as this work has
moved forward what I realize more and
more is this is a lot bigger than I
thought number one number two it's
bigger than me
see what I mean I can't do justice to
this I can't do the research that needs
to be done you know it would take a
massive effort to do the right research
massive so in my head I know kind of
what would need to be done but I can't
do it one thing we realized was that
it's not just voting preferences it's
there other things so there's a group
now one of the Max Planck Institute's in
Germany that is looking house at how C
might be affecting health decisions I'm
working with a prominent law professor
some of you may know about him Frank
Pasquale is at the University of
Maryland we are looking at whether seam
can be might be impacting
Court decisions how can that be Oh more
and more law clerks just like my lazy
friend Mike here I'm lazy too because I
I use Google Scholar now most of the
time when I'm doing you know my
scholarly searches I'm using Google
Scholar which is nuts it's kind of crazy
but and more and more law clerks are
using Google or the existing search
tools that they have used such as Lexus
and what's the other big one no no no
the the other one for law west law they
are now more and more because of studies
showing the power of Google's algorithm
for Forrester Research in cases more and
more the other tools the other
traditional tools are using Google type
approaches to their ordering to the
rankings that they do so this all kinds
of areas here that one could look at
that's a little scary because again we
we don't we have no control over this
how long do I have all right but I'll
but we want to have some chit chat right
so I'm gonna go maybe another 10 minutes
and really is the remaining time for
question okay so there's one problem
there's one issue is there probably lots
of things that this is impacting now we
have looked at other things other issues
in our experiments for example we were
wondering whether we could suppress seem
we've tried various warnings we did we
did three very large experiments in
connection with the the election this
past spring in the UK and this time we
decided to open it up to people from
many different countries so I think we
had people from 39 countries different
levels of familiarity with with the
candidates obviously so lots of
opportunity to look at demographic
issues the point is what we did though
in different groups was give people
warnings we told people this is biased
it's sometimes at the top of the page
sometimes on each item saying this
appears to be highly biased in favor of
Cameron okay
and we actually told them and when you
tell people in a in a negative and scary
way then in fact you can suppress seem
to some extent but it's still happening
but you can push it down to some extent
the only way to push it down completely
is with basically an equal time rule as
you know the FCC actually still has an
equal time rule and that's what it takes
you actually have to mix them up now
when you mix them up what are you doing
you're violating the trust of the user
and you're buiness in effect you're
giving them crappy search results right
so I can't imagine any time soon any
search engine company just you know
mixing up the results but that's the
only way you can actually suppress seem
entirely we've also been testing an
operant conditioning theory of why steam
works so well and we just completed a
very very intriguing experiment on this
issue where people in in some groups
well let's put this away everyone in
this particular cement they get some to
get to practice on our search engine
before they get into the political part
of it they get just to practice on it so
we know how it works but in half of the
groups the the practice consists of you
know doing simple searches like what is
the capital of Uganda and of course
where does the result turn up when they
get to the search results right at the
top of course so you know in those
groups they're basically getting what we
all get every day which is namely that
when we do routine searches the result
is at the top but in the other groups
these people are not getting that
they're getting the result anywhere it
could be on any page they've got to
really you know hunker down and they've
got to try to find it so we're with
those people were teaching them that for
this particular search engine you know
yeah like that top one is might not be
it okay good the result could be
anywhere well when you do that in the
first groups the average VMP that shift
toward the candidate of our choice is
44% consistent with a lot of other stuff
that we
done for the second groups the the the
low trust groups the ones that we're
we're we're messing with it drops to
seventeen percent and that number is not
statistically significant ah well that's
interesting because what this is saying
is that the reason why seam works so
well is because we are basically rats in
a skinner box footnote I was BF
Skinner's last doctoral student at
Harvard so I know a lot about rats and
Skinner boxes and basically we are rats
in a skinner box we are in routine
searches day in and day out non-stop day
in and day out over and over and over
again we are being taught the rule
what's higher is better
what's higher is true what's higher is
better what's higher is true what's
higher is better it was higher it's true
so when the time comes when we might
want to actually search on something
where we we're really not sure and
there's a big decision to be made this
makes us very vulnerable to being
influenced by whatever is higher I'm
pretty sure that's why seem is such a
big effect in fact it is one of the
largest behavioral effects ever
discovered and you know we've known for
a hundred years that lists have impact
on people we've known that for a long
long time but this is a very unique kind
of Lists effect because it is bolstered
by the training that never stops
what's higher is better tires true
what's higher is better is higher is
true there's never been a list like that
so no does this mean Google is messing
with us messing with our elections
well if nothing I've said yet scares you
this should because this is
unprecedented I think a month or two ago
doctoral meets single some of you may
know him he's the head of Google search
he published an article in Politico
criticizing me and my research what what
now all it really says is I've
encouraged you to read it in fact I put
a link to it
deliveries are really worried if you
read his don't even read my stuff just
read his I encourage you to read it
because all he really says is Google is
a really cool company and we would never
do anything like that
that's all it says I mean it's much
longer you know it's like this long but
that's all it actually says so I really
really really would encourage you to
read it because that if what I've said
so far doesn't scare you that should
scare you I published reply there's a
link to that as well let's up on
HuffPost but you know the bottom line is
this what the hell they're there they
why would they brush aside research like
this if I were running Google I would
take this very seriously because I would
I would say to the public hey you know
we're concerned about this and in fact
we want to study it we want to
understand it we want to see if there's
anything we can do to mitigate this
effect we don't want to be flipping
elections well you see that's that's
that's the problem is there's money to
be made right and obviously that's why
they're just trying to brush it off but
you can't brush this off this is too
it's it's too big you cannot brush this
off they should be the ones studying
this maybe they are well they're not I I
frankly every single time we discover
some new aspect of this it pops into my
head and I hate it so when it pops into
my head
I'm ahead Google probably knew this
three years ago I'm sure they're way
ahead of me and understanding this
phenomenon because they probably use
this phenomenon for their own purposes
now is there any evidence at all that
they actually that their search results
are biased in ways that serve the
company well some of you might be aware
that there was an internal FTC report in
the u.s. that was made public at least
parts of it were made public just within
the last year in which FTC staff said
that Google does this all the time for
many things many many things that they
biased their rankings in ways that serve
the corporate needs their corporate
needs the government of India has
concluded the same thing the European
Union has concluded same thing in India
and the EU Google is now facing at least
10 billion dollars in total fines
specifically because of biased search
rankings search rankings that serve
their company but that do not serve the
consumer and are not in fact objective
the European Union the European
Parliament excuse me and I've and I've
been invited there I've spoken to
regulators there and so on
I mean they're there they're serious
they're dead serious and what they're
doing the european parliament has voted
a few months ago now it's not it's not a
binding bow it's not that kind of thing
it's a it's a like a vote of intention
they voted by a and this was passed by a
fairly large margin in favor of a
breaking google up into small companies
exactly like our Justice Department at
AT&T in the 1980s that would be another
way of protecting the consumer from seam
because if there are lots of little
search engines they might be you know
specialized I don't know how you know
there's different ways to go about this
but if there were lots of little ones
and we use them all equally if if if I
don't the point is yes Google probably
does things like this because it's it
serves the bottom line I understand that
and yet and yet and yet I have more and
more I've actually become less concerned
about the people at Google and what they
might or might not be
doing like the little the little pranks
you know and so on I've actually become
less concerned about the people there
yes it's true that you know maybe Larry
Page could just type a couple of you
know change some parameters whatever
right through a back door or whatever
and he could he could put Hilary up in
no time
Oh Hilary G are is anyone aware that a
few months ago she hired Stephanie
Hannon away from Google to be her chief
technology officer did Barack Obama's
chief technology officer was borrowed
from Google that six other top members
of the Obama administration were all
former Google executives that according
to The Wall Street Journal Google
representatives of Google have visited
the White House since Obama came into
office ten times as many times as any
other company roughly once a week since
Obama came into office and yet I'm less
concerned about the people than
something else the algorithm because
what I've realized is again looking at
the numbers it's all in the numbers what
I realized is you don't need people you
don't need you don't need executives at
Google you know fiddling you don't need
a marius Milner fiddling who's Marius
Milner
nobody knows from there that's amazing
considering where I'm standing right now
the fact that you don't know who Marius
millinery is astonishing he is the guy
that Google said was responsible for the
street views scandal which still hasn't
gone away not not and not in terms of of
litigation for more than four years
Google's Street View vehicles were
driving up and down the streets of more
than 30 countries not just snapping
pictures but sweeping up signals from
unprotected Wi-Fi networks collecting
passwords collecting everything about
everybody in fact
I would bet a dollar that that's
probably what speak you was meant to do
but I don't know for sure this was all
blamed on Marius Miller one yeah in fact
motivated by the MIT project but doing
okay but still you have to remember the
school is an advertising company and
when and every single thing they do has
to contribute to ad revenue
everything so if you're going to
whatever it is if you if if they if they
weren't sending these vehicles up no
streets in order to collect Wi-Fi data
right you've got to tell me how simply
snapping pictures was going to increase
advertising revenue if you tell me that
I'm fine with it but that's always the
key to understanding what they're doing
their purchase of YouTube that wasn't
that was a huge area of information a
body of information about users that
they didn't have now they had it
creating chrome that was also they had
to create chrome because before chrome
they were mainly getting information
only from people who used their search
engine now that they had a browser they
you didn't need to use their search
engine least you still got all the
information about every single search
you did without you using their search
engine understand Android Android
another step up it allows them to
collect information even when you're not
in line and don't even I don't wanna
think about Google glass okay always
think how is how is it feeding the ad
machine Google cars self-driving cars
how does that feed the ad machine my
concern is with the algorithm because we
know without any doubt that the
algorithm always puts one widget ahead
of another and in elections it always
puts one candidate ahead of another so
in the election in India for example
last year if you you look at Google's
own figures on search activity Modi who
was for 60 consecutive days before the
final vote was cast his search activity
was at least 25% more than for the other
two candidates now there's a problem
here there's a kind of a feedback
potential here because if in fact search
activity and many other things I mean s
that there are many other factors
obviously but if search activity is is
one thing that might push someone higher
in rankings and if when you push someone
higher in rankings that generates more
search activity which it does there's a
potential for feedback to occur for a
synergy to occur so in the PNAS piece we
actually have a mathematical model and
we show what can happen what could
happen conceivably even if these both
are small effects if they're both small
effects nevertheless in just before an
election if it's done right you can get
an explosion of support for one
candidate because of the way those those
two factors interact we also developed
an equation which allowed us based on
easy to measure factors like projected
win margin we figured out how to predict
in advance country-by-country election
by election which elections could be
flipped using seem so you can think
about the resources we have very limited
resources if we could figure out things
like that
obviously google has much better
statistics than you do previously they
use try to use these statistics to
predict flu outbreaks oh yeah
they haven't published anything about
for using these statistics for date
selections yeah now rereads reads
singles criticism of my work just read
that that's that's the scariest thing of
all now i'm we're working on all
different aspects of this right now but
i just want to finish up by pointing to
what i think is going on here look just
like i'm trying to look at the larger
picture
there are ways in which facebook to
manipulate elections jonathan is a
trained and harvard pointed out that
based on a study that was published a
few years ago which was a collaboration
between researchers at UCSD and and
employees at facebook that you know
facebook could easily flip an election
without anyone knowing they're doing it
just by sending out go out and vote
reminders to people in one party okay
and he he calls that a digital
gerrymandering okay i told you about
seeing the search engine manipulation
effect i've tall so told you at least a
little bit about this possible synergy
and basically a digital bandwagon effect
and that's not all there's more what
we're talking about here is really new
forms of mind control that never existed
before in human human history not on
this scale and certainly never in the
hands of one small group because I don't
care whether they have 37,000 plays or
not the fact is you know this is it's a
handful of people at the top who make
the key decisions that's never happened
before never and the fact that they're
brushing aside these kinds of things
that is a problem so what's the bottom
line here the bottom line is this it's a
question
what if the mind control machine what if
the mind control machine is teaching us
not to mess with the mind control
machine and with that I welcome your
questions thank you and your name sir
I'm concerned about the implications of
this in terms of how people's mindset is
getting caused by manipulating their
attitudes towards climate change ocean
acidification and other questions that
don't have direct too many companies do
I definitely on some but the do you see
evidence that sort of do I see evidence
so here's a little anecdote from last
week where both I and one of your
colleagues here they personally spoke to
a the Committee on science technology
and law of the National Academy and I'm
starting to talk about the same research
blob of law or AM and a hand goes up
from one of the committee members who it
turns out I didn't know at the time is
actually a member of the California
Supreme Court and he goes you know
you're telling me all this is it but I
just on my on my cell phone I just
looked up and I think he said Hillary
Clinton and I looked up some one of the
other candidates he said and the search
rankings look fine to me
is what he said so you see the question
you're asking it doesn't have an easy
answer because the fact is this this is
this effect is more subtle than the old
subliminal you know stimuli thing that
was that was the rage back in the 1950s
some of you may remember this book the
hidden persuaders was number one
bestseller in 1957 and then through many
many many editions after that this was
about advertising companies what is
Google we don't know what the
conversations are there yeah we don't
answer to your husband's question what
I'm saying is you cannot look at search
rankings and figure out what's going I
can't do it okay I can't do it and I
study this I cannot look at search
rankings and and tell you you know
whether they're biased in one way or
another on an issue I can't do it I'm
I'm gonna get you in a second but what
I'm saying is more and more I'm
realizing I don't care about the people
the people could at Google or maybe Bing
to some extent and you know the other
lesser search engines they could in fact
be screwing with us in all kinds of
interesting ways you know that's
possible but in a way I don't even care
I care what the algorithm is doing
because the algorithm doing its job is
probably right now we estimate because
we developed an
equation that allows us to make the you
know to figure out which elections can
be flipped right now their algorithm
alone is probably deciding the outcome
of upwards of 25 percent of the national
elections in the world outside of China
and Russia Mike thinking one experiment
would be to take Bing and Google or is
it gold old something and look at the
order doctor cow do a simple comparison
of the bias of the headlines and see
whether the algorithms of those are
significantly different what tells
nothing it would say that being had a
different orientation I'm not saying it
couldn't be done
it would say I'm running hmm it would
tell us nothing okay Foster it would
tell us zero right
because of personalization would tell us
absolutely nothing I mean I had a one of
the attorneys general of one of the
states call me up about this and ask me
a gazillion questions and basically
between us we realized that the only
thing you could do is create thousands
of fake people and of course marketers
do this all the time we you have to
create thousands of fake people
but the problem is Google would know
they're fake because of these profiles
that's the darn problem so you see even
this you have to create thousands of
fake people you'd have to you'd have to
create different sorts of people you'd
have to be looking at the personalized
you see results that they're getting and
then maybe compare against some baseline
but Google would know that they're fake
people this is an SEO trick is to create
fake people
yeah Google has very good detectives
protecting people yeah yeah well in fact
we pay that is the federal government
paid for a PhD thesis of a guard a
sultan
losing the blur in surveys colleagues i
sat in the swirl defense to photos of it
sometime in DC when I first what it
means Google that's Aphrodite you I
could see the bias immediately the bias
was it would give you stand for results
of her birthday maths and we were paying
a million dollars to both perfectly and
my good test case actually was to try to
find the light the report which was a
very anti artificial intelligence report
and if you tried to do it using any
search engine at that point in time but
the thing is all the people who had
vested interests and search engines all
right I mean there was reference if they
just don't be criticized
James lighted no and beneath that was
the first retention that actually got a
copy
now I I've got a copy of the likable
work by a completely human way of asking
on the net as opposed to using search
engines but but it went for a long time
I watched google.com as opposed to
google that stanford.edu ultimately
lower mccartney passed away because like
oh he was one of the biggest critics of
the license work but it is actually now
possible fun Tobias criticism nao
embarrassing kind results no I'm not the
only person you should talk to I mean
there's this a whole long discussion
about what can go on with search engines
but just before you walk in the room I
was talking to you about their colleague
Louisa Gravano wouldn't find it all the
guys who written search engines but I'm
not even sure Google is now the leading
search engine since you can't use Google
in China
great I have I have friends in China and
I asked them about biting biting was
spoken here only within the last year
and one of the things that that the
people of I do do of course as they
watch very closely what first Google
does and also what I mean the Great
Firewall they know in China how to get
around the Great Firewall yeah and they
will do Google searches but they do it
only sparingly
in order since the great fire wasn't
shut down there there garnett access but
I think Google is far from but I mean
way shape or form oh these things are
happening in China with Baidu
undoubtedly and I I was on a panel
actually earlier this year in Germany
with one of the top exec second is at Y
and X which is the big Russian search
engine and there's no question that
Yandex has been used deliberately for
you know to manipulate well that
shouldn't surprise us right so all I'm
saying is you know it's not just in
Russia and China helpers IBM go back one
later so put your advertising hat back
on a whole bunch of people that are out
there trying to manipulate search
results so that the people who pay them
for manipulating search results will be
happier because their ranking goes up
that's competitive that's completely
different that's the matter because it's
putting it's spamming search engines
yeah I understand that it's competitive
but the point is the algorithms that you
want to do right there okay I want to
get rid of that spam so the Google's
algorithm is getting good there now we
get to discuss whether it gets right
there more than spam penalizing sites
which try to manipulate their ranking is
one of the larger elements of the search
engine of every search engine by Google
in particular that is to say if you
would try to use SEO they're going to
penalize you if they find you're doing
at least some of us
or straightforward simple ones and
whereas a very straightforward
presentation of information gets right
more highly than one that has an
attempted attempt to scam the search
engine system
well worse things are coming because
PageRank
you know has just been announced it's
gone no no no no there's something new
because I just read it a couple days ago
it can't be gone already is it gone
already
well doesn't give you anything it's
right there there's a number there
whether it helps anybody what as
majority of searches your beat whatever
whatever is going on the point is we
don't know we it's not transparent we
have no control we have no say and
there's there's a lot of there's a lot
of power and in fear that more than than
any small group of people in the world
has ever held before and in the US I
know from some of the people I spoke to
in Washington unaccountably mysteriously
when we investigate something almost
always and they're wrong even maybe to
two significant exceptions almost always
the investigating agency pulls back
mysteriously and so I asked why why does
this keep happening and I said well you
know campaign contributions I said wait
no these these are these are career you
know bureaucrats in Washington these
aren't they don't run they're not
elected he said no but they're appointed
and you know I think there's a serious
problem here because the reason why the
EU and why India and by the way now also
Brazil and Canada why they're being
aggressive is because they view Google
is an American company yeah here we like
that like that and we love Google we all
love Google Google is awesome I mean
their toys are incredible right and
they're getting more incredible by the
day and their their PR is amazing and
right so
we are probably you know if there really
is some danger here the dangers probably
here more than anywhere any other
questions I think we're
you